[Music]
say keep it moving in you don't reach
out for things so whatever you want
you'll reach up for the head make that
same function don't let the EDP not get
harmed goes off to the side doing it
again
[Music]
don't know they might want to do that
you don't don't let them yeah then my
body would okay just got your torque in
the shoulders hey go you get the
direction you're going
I'm alive please you don't get to start
over
you have a lot of tension in your lower
legs oh my goodness
[Music]
most of times it's fake so if you go
ahead and you turn for me and then you
would do you know you have to keep
tension in the elbow you understand yes
so there's this not this okay and I
don't know what it's going to be because
as you move I have to move you see how
do you understand that
so it's more of a feeling a feeling some
people will want to fall on you once
they figure out put our hash go ahead
right and then the arm has their
attention again for your training you
don't ever let that ha pitch no going
attention okay there you go like this no
tension tension you see it works as a
lever not just here the whole thing is
worth right get out
well to our whole Center be detention in
the arm
[Music]
wearing this up a now I don't want to
make that doesn't work I get em you see
that that's to me a touch that's why you
end up on this news okay so you're gonna
hear coming around here oh you get to
see the different stuff I'm around here
I like this no that's a big person's
technique so boom boom each same thing
goes up the head here know if your fall
is that X boom that's right to touch my
home same thing they're not contact here
and then shove them up we touch it extra
[Music]
lower it
rather than shove it down partners I on
me
- goofy now that's pre X if you're not
big enough and it's not Aikido
everything counts in bullfighting we're
not standing behind the cave there's is
that slack all in that arm do it right
get your butt down back straight we're
gonna start shortchanging
[Music]
you don't hold the floor right so you
just have to be discipline if you hang
it here got it
not here we're here you're in here relax
no one's even thrown you yet right
you're here this is where I enter I
don't pull you down down here you
already there you see you gotta find the
wrist let's say you can't get the wrist
right all I can't slide down there okay
forget it
pull you just pull that bad technique
out you're gonna let go of it but you're
working Shiho nage you have the wrist
okay hi
better keep going that's it
spying who cares just then go with the
cheetah we had your weight on your heels
and your knees versus if you don't go
backwards get on the wrist if you don't
have the wrist
forget the technique
gotta get her elbow that's it
change frightens yo - yo D let's go
[Music]
thank you whatever they wanted to
understand so I'm not gonna go like this
and pick them up you know that's not if
they're in a position to Savannah's you
keep the disadvantaged she's down there
right I'm good here
don't pick them back up especially with
the throwing arm
all right no
[Music]
keep the top arm in front knee and
ground yourself stop bouncing off the
ground get some friction going we still
oh you're just pushing them around
develop some gravity
I would picked it going underneath the
arm of somebody that's like a foot or
more shorter than I am bigger eating
better
get the wrists are too high you're too
high bar the secret goes at the carpals
[Music]
run and come with Leah you're gonna get
running and go fast I mean fast go nice
weird
deep train come on let's go each time
faster keep going
oh we're you're not a big slug between
reps now is that how it is you don't
discipline yourself it's all gonna be
external always you can always need me
she did go back with her
thin line between rats stay alive now -
for going slow stayin alive stay alive
got it cheeseburgers muddled - Dottie
that's a good base no it's not right
you're holding your breath yeah too much
you left your pushing up - you're
pushing too much on his map
do you actually do the Friday the 13th
Joe from Arsenal No
[Music]
don't you don't have to give up yet
like I come here right there like that
okay right here he's couldn't get his
balance again for a split second easy
right so here like it I don't get it
just go off of that if you never give
them back your Center you're doing the
same thing on this one here here here
every time you give them balance oh I'm
trying this one oh there's a lot of
pressure on there but come underneath
whoa
cake don't leg out be very wary you come
in here like that and then you pass
through that face all right it's not
like you don't love all that you're
gonna and they're gonna go something has
to be there so I'm going like that right
maybe I'm there oh maybe my strikes
there oh we're gonna coming back up boom
you see and I'm not just going one chin
some balance
take the bang don't have it look here
finish it don't follow me down down why
are you throwing up you wanna pin and
pin them ski
that's pre X now now now
start again you can't give him back his
balance the no Akua
[Music]
if you know any guillotines oh then are
mad to stay in front of you and we don't
pick them up with the throwing them back
take her back take it back oh you're not
no you just gave in fact you had control
the arm then you gave her back
that was not a locked arm boom right go
ahead do it ever right so you're there
right okay fine
boom right in the fire boom boom boom
boom boom especially when they're
disbanding you're like gotta gotta
technique gotta give thanks you're
missing all the other openings because
no no that's exactly what I'm talking
about
[Music]
find your tummy you look like you don't
know any strike without true
that's weird then throw a knee that's it
get that knee in there right in his face
or not knee boom wake up wake up knee
you look asleep do you do I need to be
your partner
[Music]
start choking him out he's open for it
every time learn practice it practice it
[Music]
me come on let's go good good
keep your ground pass feet on the ground
for Jack good so Jack go picture I'm
gonna do it Joe
it should be where it goes right
[Music]
that I'm gonna do an e that's the same
problem I'm gonna do cuz they Gotama
it's the same problem start sucking it
up
you're back to sleep you back to sleep
now that means you're a liar because you
told me you didn't teach me you're
sleepy liar
[Music]
we don't say like that hey okay put your
arm up
hold your base get your base so I'm not
moving and you follow me I've created a
connection with them do you understand
so see it see how I can can move you
okay that's what I'm doing it's not your
job to stay with me hi do you got it
hi so if you as you go to punch I have
that connection
okay I'm doing that I get maybe grab you
see when you don't come around
do you understand okay your job I can do
kick not this
that's my job
can you move me or not well you got it
yes go don't stand in the way of the
bull find your basic you don't know it
you don't know it just let it go you
don't know it you're supposed to though
aren't you yes yes just to waste your
teachers time are you it's just weird
[Music]
no one's gonna hit you in the face when
you're defending yourself what do you
think yeah you just gonna quit too
you gotta let me quit so maybe I have
some tension and I'll feel honorable
it's like there's the door and there's
no door so you need evening hi do you
understand okay you don't throw the limp
bar and you don't spin around this
radius okay so I have this arm and the
arm goes limp don't do this cuz it's not
affecting your base right you see that
so are you good here arm goes limp is
like you might take me you just come in
it should be automatic that's you feel
the vacuum and you come right here okay
that way you're not moving around you're
gonna control their arm when they're
just down
you know each oh now you do know each
other
[Music]
so start paying attention how fast you
move and how fast I'm okay and what's
your feeling from okay say you go here
we go you're slowing down a beat agents
happen I'm late
yeah that's what I have to hurt okay so
try to have it whether you're out here
your timing the openings you started
earlier so you'd have to race there okay
[Music]
it's too high again you have to lower
too high again
do you know any guillotines do you know
any jokes from the front you're turning
them do you have control so where do you
want to go all the way down I don't see
all the way down I don't see it
remember not to follow him down on your
projections that's why we have stumps
[Music]
I'll know what that is
kiss I got Tamas just ass down